we have a second allegation of sexual
misconduct against judge Brett Kavanaugh
this morning it raises new questions
about his Supreme Court nomination one
of his Yale classmates tells in New
Yorker magazine that Cavanaugh exposed
himself to her at a party about 35 years
ago she wants an FBI investigation
Cavanaugh says the accusation is a smear
the authors of the article say no
eyewitnesses have confirmed that he was
even at the party the story follows
Christine Blasi Ford's decision to
testify at a Senate hearing on Thursday
about her claim that Cavanaugh sexually
assaulted her in high school
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy
good morning good morning the second
accuser went public
just after Christine Blasi Ford
officially accepted the Senate Judiciary
Committee's invitation to testify about
her claims on Thursday Kavanagh denies
both allegations but the calls for an
outside investigation have grown louder
and some senators wonder whether his
nomination can now survive
Debra Ramirez lives in Colorado and has
worked with victims of domestic violence
according to The New Yorker article when
she and Kavanagh were first-year
students at Yale he quote exposed
himself at a drunken dormitory party
thrust his penis in her face and caused
her to touch it without her consent as
she pushed away Ramirez admits her
memories contained gaps because she had
been drinking at the time of the alleged
incident but some of her classmates
confirmed to Ronan Farrow and Jane Mayer
they were told at the time about it
while others said they had zero
recollection in a statement Kavanagh
insisted this alleged event from 35
years ago did not happen the people who
knew me then know that this did not
happen and have said so California
Democrat Dianne Feinstein is now calling
for Thursday's hearing with Christine
Blasi Ford to be canceled while other
Senate Democrats called on Kavanagh to
withdraw due to a pattern of conduct
saying it's time for a new nominee
Republicans laid low they had been
pushing for a quits confirmation just a
few hours earlier unless there's
something more no I'm not going to ruin
judge kapnos life over this this was
vice president Mike Pence on Saturday I
believe the judge Brett Kavanaugh will
soon be Justice Brett Kavanaugh and take
his seat on the Supreme Court as for
Ford
Cavanaugh's first accuser I believe her
completely
Ford's sister-in-law says it's a
difficult time but she's prepared to
testify facts matter to her and so she's
being careful to make sure that this
process will be fair and I don't think
that's too much to ask amid all of this
the lawyer Michael avenatti says he has
a client who will go public this week
with more information about Cavanaugh
and his friends plying girls with
alcohol and sexually assaulting them in
high school Republicans say they're very
skeptical about those claims until they
see more but avenatti tells me he
doesn't traffic in rumors and that his
client is very credible Norah
all right Nancy thank you